make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
why hello rob koi how are you guys doing
today you know
there is a rumor circulating around out
there that omega red
is going to appear in falcon and the
winter soldier
and i really hope that's true i really
hope it's a true rumor nothing's
confirmed at the moment
but i really hope it's true and the
reason why is because if it is then
god it ties into everything right like
the red room captain america all that
kind of stuff i'll explain why over the
course of this video
i hear comics explain i'm always focused
on turning you guys into a comic book
expert in 30 minutes or less and in this
video
we are going to do that so omega red
first appeared in marvel comics with
x-men volume 2 issue number four
in january of 1992 and he was created by
john byrne and jim lee but omega red
is a perfect example of one of these
characters who was a great character
that showed up at the wrong time and the
reason why is because
this was kind of a transition point in
marvel comics right so those of you guys
who are familiar with this era in marvel
who have been reading for a long time or
who have been part of this channel for a
long time
bear with me here for a second because
i'm going to run over this for people
who are totally unfamiliar with all this
stuff
so x-men volume 2 is is probably the
single
highest selling comic in the history of
comic books right x-men volume 2 issue
number one because
it had come off the heels of chris
claremont's 17-year run on the character
but the issue that you had
was that claremont had basically gone
into x-men vol 2 and then almost
immediately left he went over to dc
comics to write something called the
sovereign seven which sucked
but x-men was hugely popular because of
the 17-year run of chris claremont
you've probably heard of stories like
the phoenix saga the dark phoenix saga
days of future past that was all chris
claremont right and so he had built this
team up
so huge that when it was relaunched in
1991 it was enormous right everybody
loved the idea of it and so omega red
was brought in by the time chris
claremont had left john vernon of course
had taken over and omega red was brought
in to be kind of a continuation of this
sort of
high-octane fast-paced method of
storytelling and that was the big thing
in the 90s right the 80s were more
i wouldn't really say like darker and
grittier they were to a degree because
of stories like the dark knight returns
by frank miller which kind of brought in
the idea of like a darker method of
storytelling but the reality is that
story was kind of
it wasn't really landmark in that way
because if you go back and you read like
chris claremont's x-men run or you go
back and you read
uh things like you know the night when
stacey died by jerry conway
then you already knew that comics were
going in that direction right so i
always kind of feel like that's a false
attribute to give to the dark knight
returns
it's basically shoveling a whole bunch
of praise onto a comic for like changing
the dynamic of comics in a way that it
hadn't really done
but the idea behind omega red being
introduced was one of these things where
it tied into something called the
russian kgb
and department x but in his original
introduction much like wolverine at the
time
we didn't really know a whole lot about
his character right all that was told to
us while we were shown
was that you essentially had a guy by
the name of matsuo who was the leader of
a group called the hand now the hand of
marvel comics kind of an aside here the
hand and marvel comics are like a
mystical ninja organization you saw them
if you watch like the daredevil netflix
series or or like the defenders or
something like that
the idea was that at some point in
feudal japan you had multiple tribes or
multiple groups who had basically
defected away from what was considered
to be the imperial kingdom of japan
and took off to the mountains to to do
their own thing right just study like
ninjitsu and all that kind of stuff then
you had a guy by the name of kaganobu
yoshioka who basically banded them all
together and then they started
worshipping a being called the beast who
gave them like all their mystical
abilities to resurrect the dead and
different things along those lines by
this point a guy named matsuo
is basically running the show he
basically ends up traveling to discover
the container
of omega red and then alongside like
professor cornelius and a few other
people
basically wake him up and then show him
a picture of wolverine now the reality
of this is they had done that for the
purpose of analyzing omega red
to see whether or not his like quote
unquote fabled stamina as great as it
was supposed to be
if he was really a person they could use
for their own ants and so what they did
is they orchestrated a situation whereby
they told him where wolverine was
located
and because the history of the two of
them shared which had not been revealed
to that point omega red traveled to the
xavier institute alongside a whole bunch
of members of the hand and they
basically fought all the x-men and then
kidnapped wolverine and took him to
berlin
and what this did is it led to a 17-hour
fight between
omega red and wolverine himself now
omega red's inherent mutant ability is
what's called
death spores basically he can just kind
of emit these pheromones that will in
effect
kill you but because of wolverine's
healing factor they didn't kill him but
it did allow omega red to get the upper
hand on wolverine and that's where a lot
of the backstory began to come into play
that because of the nature of
wolverine's history when he fought as
part of team
x which as we've talked about before was
a 1960s cold war era black ops team uh
one of the
tasks that they had was to one free a
woman who went by the name of janus
janice hollenbeck who is basically like
a double agent but at the same time to
also capture something called the
carbonadium synthesizer
and once they did that because they had
captured that synthesizer that's the
reason why omega red is constantly after
them because that went into what was in
effect the origin of omega red now of
course the fight kind of continued on
and he and wolverine fought himself you
know fought each other a little bit
longer in the story and then that was it
right it was a two-part story in x-men
vol 2 issues 5-6
technically with his debut in x-men
volume 2 issue number four but before we
get into that origin
a little bit of information here that
you need to know if you want to be an
expert on omega red
the the fact that i say he was a great
character who appeared at the wrong time
goes into the comic boss of the 1990s
and we don't necessarily need to go
super in depth into that we've made a
video talking about that before
and i'll link it down in the description
but in effect what you had here was a
situation where people were going out
and buying like the first appearance of
characters or the relaunch of comics
like x-men volume 2 issue number one
with the expectation that it would
increase in value almost exponentially
but the more of something you have the
less that thing ends up being worth and
so where you had marvel comics that was
printing out like 12 different covers
for the first issue of a number one and
everybody was buying it then suddenly
those comics were worth a lot less right
so basically comic book fans and
collectors ended up almost killing the
comic book market and so around the time
that omega red debuted that's when
everything started to go belly up right
because where jim lee's art was iconic
with the x-men with x-men volume 2.
he took off in 1993 to go form image
comics alongside like mark silvestri and
a whole bunch of other guys
and so the result of this is that uh
marvel ended up in this position
in the mid-1990s where they were like
okay we're only going to publish
characters that are exceedingly
important everything else we're going to
contract out to
other companies right that's where jimmy
palmiati and joe casada's event
publications came from right if you
don't know what that means not a great
big huge deal the important thing to
understand here is that as far as omega
red goes his origin was never covered in
the actual x-men comics instead it was
covered in what we're called
outlier comics or comics that would
appear kind of out there or comics that
would come
much much later on right now an example
of an outlier comic comes in the form of
what's called
maverick right now maverick was part of
team x and he was a character who had
a little bit of popularity he was by no
means big enough to hold his own title
and we know that because marvel tried it
a couple times right you had a you had
the original maverick comic published in
1997 and then you had a second follow-up
that came
with that was 12 issues long but he was
never really popular enough to hold his
own series that was a point in marvel
when they were just grasping at straws
and just publishing anything that was
almost in relation to wolverine or close
enough to wolverine because wolverine
was just so incredibly popular in marvel
comics uh but between the generation x
run in 1993 so essentially generation x
issues 10 and 11
the maverick solo series in 1997 and
weapon x vol
3 issue number 20 in 2018 the origin
of omega red comes together in this idea
that at some point in russia's past
there was a guy by the name of arcadie
rosovich and arcadie was born with the
mutant ability of again
death sports the ability to basically
emanate these pheromones that would kill
you
and so what we found is that because of
this mutant ability that he had he kind
of became obsessed with death
and he would basically engage in these
pretty heinous acts that involved like
homeless people or like kids or
different things like that
but he ended up joining the russian army
and became part of spetsnaz and
continued his
kind of enjoyment of of essentially
killing people but this all came to a
head when he was transferred to the
antarctic and the reason why
is because with this being a much
smaller community the fact that people
went missing was something that was
eventually noticed
and so the way it's told from kestrel in
the old mavericks series
is that ultimately when it was
discovered that he was engaging in these
heinous acts he was executed by his
superiors at the time like they
literally put him in a cell they put a
gun to the back of his head and they
shot him in the head
and supposedly killed him the reality
was he ended up saving
ended up surviving because of his mutant
powers right is his basically his
healing factor and so when that took
place what you ended up getting was him
being taken or at least
the idea was he was supposed to be taken
by the russian government and used in
their super soldier program we'll talk
about the significance of that here in a
minute because that's how it ties into
captain america
ultimately at the time at least at this
point in the 1960s and 1970s
magneto had not quite become magneto yet
but he had separated from charles xavier
right so this is kind of the follow-up
to
their first encounter when they met in
egypt and they realized they both had
powers but their ideologies were so
different that they couldn't consolidate
and so they just kind of went their own
way and so where magneto had continued
to use the name eric lyncher
and just traveled across the world he
ultimately ended up coming across or at
least
uh encountering sean cassidy who would
later go on to become banshee but who at
the time was an interpol agent and then
the idea
was to essentially assign him and try
and have him track down uh omega red
ultimately sean cassidy was successful
in doing that and handed handed omega
red
over to the authorities but omega red
was then taken by the kgb
now here's the reason why that matters
so why the clock back to like the 1940s
right steve rogers is injected with the
super soldier serum by abraham erskine
he becomes captain america abraham
erskine dies almost immediately steve
rogers was believed to have been killed
but he was really just frozen in a block
of ice what this meant was that the
united
states had no real way of continuing the
super soldier program
and so one thing to understand here is
that when it comes to the super soldier
program as it exists in marvel comics
when it was originally introduced it was
just the federal government trying to
create super soldiers to fight the axis
powers over the years marvel
has expanded on that particularly with
grant morrison's new x-men
and what that story told us is that
captain america as far as the federal
government was publicly concerned uh
captain america was just the first in a
series of super soldiers that would
essentially bolster the united states
military
and allow the united states to take on
credible threats like the axis powers to
gain the upper hand in world war ii
and whatever threats may come after that
unknown to even the federal government
itself
uh the captain america project rebirth
situation was basically a was was the
first stage in a series of weapons that
were created by
weapons plus and weapons plus
overarching goal was essentially a
precursor to project wide awake
containing control the mutant threat and
so the federal government
didn't actually know what was going on
with weapons plus they were duped just
like everybody else the reality was
captain america was designed to be the
first in a series of super soldiers that
could take on the mutant threats that
existed out there that was covered in
grant morrison's new x-men and so what
we ended up finding out or at least what
we kind of had to presume there was that
assuming steve rogers didn't actually
freeze in a block of ice and had
returned home successful that world war
ii was a field test and presumably much
like the russians did with bucky barnes
that the united states government or at
least weapons plus would wipe his mind
and plant false memories and send him
out there as the first in a series of
super soldiers designed to take on
mutants as we know
none of that happened and so because
there was no way to duplicate the super
soldier serum you just went forward with
weapons plus having like weapons
2 and weapon 3 weapon 4 so on and so
forth all the way up to weapon x
or wolverine now the actions of the
united states in regards to captain
america
did not go unnoticed and so what the
what the russian government did by way
of their kgb
is they created what was called
department x and department x was
was essentially its own weapons plus
program creating super soldiers
some of these things may be familiar
some of them may not but two of the
biggest things to come out of the
russian kgb
during the cold war was project winter
soldier which we know from bucky barnes
and the red room which created like
black widow like all the black widows
that existed out there as essentially
assassins for omega red himself what
ended up happening
is that once he was handed over to the
authorities by sean cassidy
and then taken by the kgb the kgb began
implanting these different cybernetic
implants inside of him
as well as bonding him to carbonadium
now carbonadium was basically a poor
man's version of adamantium that when
iron maclaine created adamantium
because it was so incredibly expensive
to make and because russians did not
readily have the formula they created
the closest thing they could which
turned out to be carbonadium now the
carbonadium tendrils that were installed
inside of a mega red really kind of
allowed him to just sort of attack
people to ensnare them right to have you
know
an extension of its power that could be
used by virtue of these these tentacles
but the important thing is that when
that happened he went forward officially
as omega red
and was essentially supposed to be like
their own super soldier right something
akin to like wolverine or captain
america from the united states and north
america
but all of this was basically book ended
into his first appearance and his desire
to attain
the carbonation synthesizer because with
the carbonadium tendrils being attached
to his body
it was slowly poisoning him right like
the adamantium inside of wolverine's
body the difference is that the healing
factor of omega red
was not necessarily on the same level as
as wolverines in marvel comics but at
the same time carbonadium was also far
more poisonous and radioactive than
adamantium was and so the result was
that even with his healing factor
despite it being
somewhat limited he wasn't able to
overcome it and has always kind of been
a thing with omega red that even when
his healing factor was bolstered later
on that he still couldn't overcome the
carbonation and poisoning going on in
his body and so he was always on the
hunt for the carbonadium synthesizer
which he could use to effectively
stabilize quote unquote his body
and keep the carbonadium from poisoning
him but the other big takeaway from here
is that where this kind of origin
despite it taking place over different
comics was ultimately designed to kind
of lead
into his first appearance that with this
initial showing in x-men volume 2 that
the story wrapped up
pretty quickly in comparison to what you
think it would be that it was basically
just kind of field testing and seeing
like what is omega red capable of if he
really is over
able to take over wolverine who is by
all standards of measurement considered
to be the deadliest person in the world
because of his healing factor because of
his berserker rage because of all of his
military and martial arts training and
so on and so forth uh if he can take out
wolverine then that gives us an upper
hand right not necessarily in taking on
the x-men
but in using omega red for a multitude
of like assassination attempts or
toppling governments or whatever
nefarious intentions the hand had for
him uh with him being able to display
the fact that he could take out
wolverine that was considered to be a
great thing
right the problem with this is that
again he was still on the hunt for the
carbonation synthesizer which ultimately
wolverine ended up giving to
to his former teammate maverick and they
just kind of went forward from there the
problem with omega red
is that following this there wasn't a
whole lot of great stuff going on with
this character that by the time this
story arc finished
marvel was starting to go belly up right
marvel was literally starting to go
broke and had it not been for like avia
rod and ike perlmutter and those guys
essentially bailing marvel out and then
eventually the launch of marvel studios
that marvel would have gone bankrupt
right and so the results of this is that
you didn't see a whole lot doing with
omega red you saw some stuff and you saw
some cool things but it was marvel kind
of circulating him around to existing
stories for the purpose of seeing
whether or not he could actually build
up any great stories on his own now one
of the first and most notable examples
of this came in iron man issue number
297 by len kaminsky and this was
marvel's attempt to like
move omega red just completely away from
like the x-men mythos
and just have him face off against
somebody who had nothing to do with the
x-men now the reality was with iron man
he was not quite at the level of
popularity he would have with like
civil war and then eventually the marvel
cinematic universe so he was one of
these characters where he was only
hugely popular
within comic book fans themselves but
that was enough for marvel comics to
take a shot at it and so the way this
played out is you had what was called
modam who was basically a woman by the
name of olinka baronkova and she was
essentially the female version of modoc
if you don't really know who that is
it's not a great big huge deal it was
designed to kind of introduce some small
elements of of the past of omega red and
saying that like him and alinka had
history together
honestly nothing really big ever came
out of this there wasn't really a whole
lot going there and so the next attempt
that marvel made
came in cable in the cable solo series
as it was written
in the 1990s now the intention of doing
this was to still kind of keep omega red
away from the x-men
but close enough that he could still
kind of maintain that popularity that
was built in x-men volume 2. and so with
fabian necessa writing cable at the time
cable was huge in the 1990s right he was
hugely popular because his mystery is
what drove the intrigue right all we
knew was that he was basically the child
of cyclops and the clone of jean grey a
woman named madeleine pryor
from the future now much later on in the
late 1990s marvel would flesh that out
with the adventures of jean grey and
cyclops or the adventures of cyclops in
phoenix is technically what it's called
but at the time cable was hugely
intriguing but he was also kind of a
reflection of comics at the time which
was
super high octane fast pace so that's
why you saw him teaming up with like gw
bridge and people like that he had like
a ton of little pouches and things like
that he was colossal in size
you know it was it was a really cool
element of comics at that point in time
and so him facing off against cable
again kind of continuing to try to find
this this carbanium synthesizer proved
to be hugely popular among fans
and so this kind of resurgence happened
with this character where the story went
on for a number of
issues it started in cable issue number
nine and then ran all the way up to
cable issue number 11 with a few other
appearances
following that and that was enough for
marvel to kind of continue on and say
okay
let's see if we can't like tie him back
into the x-men see if we can't bring him
a little bit closer
and so what you saw going into the early
2000s was a couple of different stories
the first was called the logan files and
the second was called the hunt for
sabretooth now the logan files took
place or at least this part of the logan
files took place what was called x-men
liberators now x-men liberators was just
a mini-series that was launched in 1998
that went into 1999 and just focused on
colossus and nightcrawler which
kind of you know kind of a family
reunion then it was away from marvel in
the
really the latter half of the comic bust
going into the early 2000s to try to see
if it wasn't really possible to focus on
a story that involved other characters
beyond the core x-men group
and it was moderately successful right i
mean it wasn't by any means huge right
it wasn't like this huge blockbuster
comic or anything like that
you ended up having omega red facing off
against uh colossus and nightcrawler the
whole idea behind this was for omega red
to basically fight alongside lady
deathstrike in you know taking on
wolverine and his closest friends and so
on and so forth but the exchange that
was offered here is that if omega red
agreed to help sabertooth that he would
basically get information belonging to
weapon x right all these different
mutants that were out there which would
kind of continue the campaign of of
omega red like one taking out you know
people he considered to be enemies but
two
continuing to hunt for the carbonadium
synthesizer the results of this is that
this comic went directly into the hunt
for sabertooth storyline that was
covered in the weapon x vol 2 series
starting with issue number three or at
least starting with issue number one
going into issue number three and then
four five and six and the whole point
here was
that with sabertooth effectively
betraying uh omega red
and lady deathstrike he essentially took
off this brought back the character of
agent zero who was in reality maverick
and then just kind of led to you know
the two of them getting into a fight and
then omega red facing off against a few
other people here and there and
different things along those lines but
again
you know the the long and short of this
is that following his original
appearance going into the late 1990s and
the early 2000s there wasn't much doing
with the character of omega red now any
attempt that marvel
really had in trying to bring this whole
thing back basically came to a head with
a house of imp and the reason for this
is again kind of tying back into our
discussion about jimmy palmiotti
and anjokasada event publications that
with joe casada kind of leaving event
publications alongside jimmy palmiotti
and officially being inducted as the
editor-in-chief of marvel comics the
stance was the comic boss is what almost
killed marvel in terms of all the
different mutant characters they had
writing too many books all that kind of
stuff and so he wanted to make things a
lot simpler right bring things back to
the way that they used to be
make things a lot smaller create some
more familiarity and then just kind of
rebuild from the ground up and so
particularly with regards to house of m
this is the story that saw 98 of the
mutant population losing their powers
and only 198 mutants were allowed to
kind of quote unquote remain and existed
at the xavier institute
you did see omega red pop up here again
kind of on the hunt for the carbonation
synthesizer the belief being that it had
been handed over to black widow who had
basically hid it in brussels
of course this led to him facing off
against black widow and then ultra
ultimately wolverine and then eventually
being captured by shield agents and
handed over to shield themselves but
that's kind of how that went right i
mean following that
you did have uh another appearance that
came in uncanny x-men issue number 499
where he faced off against colossus and
nightcrawler again that he was basically
taken by the red room and kind of
brought into their their whole thing and
then you know you essentially had him
in effect killed uh in the daniel way
x-men origin storyline that basically
kind of contained both past and present
stories but again it was away from all
the kind of writer's character out right
by that point marvel kind of looked at
omega red and said okay
there's really not much going on with
this character there's really not much
interest here he's considered to be old
hat we're trying to re
you know kind of relaunch and recreate
everything so shuffle this guy off to
the cornfields oh mega red's no longer
part of the picture
we'll bring him back if we need to and
it stayed that way for a number of years
but eventually he was brought back
in x-men gold vol 2 as part of all new
all-different marvel with the all-new
all different marvel relaunch
now the return of omega red in this
particular story was not well received
not so much because it was omega red but
because of how it was done
that marvel had created an organization
called sickle which was basically just
like russia's version
of shield now unlike the existence of
shield which exists to kind of safeguard
earth from various threats that kind of
existed on earth itself to kind of tap
into various intelligence organizations
that sickle was very much an anti-mutant
organization that ran something called
the straining corrective labor camp
which basically just used mutants or
imprisoned mutants as a form of labor or
just kind of kept them locked down
as a way to sort of keep them from
becoming a credible threat to russia
itself right so think of like a mini
genocide
inside of russia uh the result was that
sicko being led by the
by vasily who was the brother of the
estranged brother basically the
long-lost brother of
omega red at the time but nobody really
liked it and this happened for a couple
different reasons one because the story
was not very well written
but two because the idea of comics being
more adult oriented and being as violent
as they used to be in the 1990s had
basically been removed and the
characters were a lot more toned down
that omega red was not nearly as
as intense as he was in the past instead
he was just kind of like you know i'm a
mega rat and i do some things you know
and that's basically it
and fans weren't really receptive to
that right that they basically saw omega
red as being part and parcel to the
1990s and this perception of his
character
stayed right it just kind of stayed that
way and that's why you never really saw
omega red despite showing up in like the
weapon x-force despite showing up in
like age of x-men different things like
that and even running now
to the modern day and showing up in the
wolverine vol 7 series that people just
don't really see him the way they used
to that in a lot of ways omega red is
just kind of considered to be one of the
characters that marvel had that was
really really awesome that they kind of
screwed up as time went on now whether
it'll stay that way
we don't really know i mean marvel is a
lot more toned down than it used to be
but they're not nearly as hyper violent
as they used to be a lot of that's just
because of the change in society as a
whole
the comics especially because of the
marvel cinematic universe are becoming a
lot more family friendly as opposed to
like you know like this is omega red and
he's just like killing people you know
all that kind of stuff and like you know
a murderous guy
and things like things along those lines
it's not really the case anymore so
those
that era is long since gone the biggest
question that a lot of people like
myself have is
you know with the idea of him being the
way that he was will that ever come back
the answer that question is probably no
right so omega red is not really an
interesting character anymore but
he is a character that used to be wildly
interesting back in the 1990s but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you